from khan academy welcome to the daily
homeroom live stream for those of y'all
that this is your first time this is
really just a way for us to stay
connected during school closures
obviously khan academy we have many
resources for students teachers and
parents to be able to work
whether the school is in session
physically or whether it's happening at
home as as i think most of y'all are now
having to cope with and we realize above
and beyond those resources in math and
english and language arts and science
and humanities that go from pre-k
through college that we need to provide
more supports it's our duty as a
not-for-profit with a mission to provide
a free world-class education for anyone
anywhere to step up right now in this
this time of crisis and so that's why
we're doing teacher webinars parent
webinars uh this daily homeroom live
stream for everyone as well as
things like
the daily schedules that many of y'all
are now leveraging to think about how to
structure your days for students of
different age groups i will remind
everyone as i always do that we are a
not-for-profit organization and
we are supported the only reason we can
exist is because of philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself and
even before this crisis we were
operating at a deficit and now during
this crisis our server traffic is up two
and a half approaching three times our
registrations for
students and parents are actually
students and teachers or six-fold parent
registrations or 20-fold so if you're in
a position to do so please think about
donating to khan academy i do want to
give a special shout out to several
corporations who stepped up in record
time when they
realized that we needed help not just
generally but especially in this covid
response period bank of america stepped
up in that first weekend followed by at
t google.org and now novartis
this has been incredible help any of you
who are corporate leaders or work for
corporations we need more help so i
would love to add logos to this and for
all of you individuals out there we
still are running at a significant
deficit so every donation matters
whether it's as small as the three
dollar donation five dollar ten dollar
we know that that is hard earned money
and it and and we really appreciate it
but we really do need it if we want to
support kids around the world and
parents and teachers so today we have a
fairly exciting
live stream we have a clinical
psychologist david anderson i encourage
everyone i say this every time to start
putting questions on facebook and
youtube that you might have for either
our guest dave or myself about anything
but we're going to talk about something
that is very front of mind for a lot of
folks right now
we are all socially distanced many of us
have kids at home kids are trying to
stay learning but there's many other
things that are going on in all of our
minds anxiety is up stress is up for
everyone and i'm hoping dave can help us
navigate and i'm speaking not just as a
representative of the khan academy
community i'm also speaking as a
a parent who has seen
some of some of our uh some of the
difficulties of what we're going through
so
thanks for joining us dave and you know
maybe the first question is any general
advice
you have for parents and students who
are just trying to cope with everything
going on right now
right well look thanks for having me uh
it's wonderful to be able to be here and
have a forum to kind of talk about some
of these things you know uh we have a
practice on both coasts about 60
clinicians in the child mind institute
we're hearing a lot
from parents and students i would say
that you know the first things that are
the top of mind especially for parents
are to manage expectations i mean the
biggest thing is that none of us have
encountered challenges like this before
and i count myself within that with two
children um you know it's something
where trying to manage the the work
lives that we were uh attempting to
manage before this crisis hit with uh
child care and without many of the major
supports that we have uh in a time of
online schooling is tough and it's going
to be tough for anybody so some of the
first things we talk to parents about
are taking the to-do lists and the kind
of level of perfectionism they would
normally expect themselves and really
trying to edit those things down as much
as possible to ensure that there's
something manageable each day and you
have a moment to kind of mindfully pause
and perhaps enjoy
some of the silver linings of this in
terms of time spent with family and an
opportunity to connect a little bit more
and what should we keep a lookout on for
our children or even for ourselves i
know you focus on on children especially
but as a clinical psychologist generally
you know i think sometimes you can
things can happen in bits and pieces and
you know you've gone too far before it
and it's too late what should we look
out for signs of difficulty in our kids
or even ourselves
i mean the reality to your point is that
we always say this that child therapy is
so much about it being mediated by the
parents and parents aren't necessarily
the cause of the child's particular
difficulties but they're often the
solution so we spend a probably about
half the time spending talking to
parents even when the child might be the
particular focus of our intervention and
you know in terms of how parents can
support kids at the moment and what we
can we can help them to think about
especially with online schooling because
i'll go back to any earlier questions um
it's that you know we're
everybody's adapting this kind of new
normal like schools are trying to
outline assignments uh in certain ways
and make it so that uh it's manageable
for the kids and they may not
necessarily be getting data in real time
from parents related to what the kids
can handle and what kind of scaffolding
they need i think the kids we're
especially concerned about at the moment
for for our clinical population are
those of mental health and learning
disorders that normally are supported in
allowing them access to a school
curriculum in school but which you know
we may see a lack of those kinds of
support services or where parents are
being asked to be therapist speech
language pathologist and teacher all in
one and that's something that's
exceedingly difficult for everybody
right now and how are you all supporting
those parents or supporting those
students
yeah a lot of it is is retooling uh our
clinical services to be uh digital at
this time so
in many ways we're starting from a kind
of uh population focused prevention
level in the child mind institute now
has two facebook lives per day
there's a section the website which you
can see here
on coronavirus support and resources uh
just for supporting families it includes
links to our daily tips and facebook
lives a link to phone consultations we
can provide right now for families are
having difficulty and then also articles
that are really focused on coping with
coronavirus crisis we've tried to make
those articles targeted to age groups to
parent stress management the
incorporation of mindfulness and then
specific diagnostic clusters where
parents may be experiencing
certain kind of unique difficulties say
for kids on the autism spectrum or kids
who might have difficulty with behavior
so i thank you for scrolling through uh
that section of our website right there
you can also i'll be doing these
facebook lives twice next week so if uh
folks have questions that go unanswered
between you and me sal they can catch me
again a little bit later
this is super useful and we're getting a
lot of interesting questions here for
you dave
this first one is from youtube molly
franklin asks as an extrovert how can i
keep from losing my mind during
quarantine exclamation mark
that's that's a really good question i
mean you know i think that in many ways
we've seen an explosion of these kind of
self-categorizing terms on twitter and
on the internet right now where folks
realize like in terms of the definition
of extrovert we see it operationalized
right now and
on the internet as somebody really gets
their energy and really feels like their
mood gets a boost in any given day from
the contact the close contact in person
that they have with other people that's
where they get their energy and so look
what we try to do at first is help
extroverts to uh cope in a sort of
accepting way in that we know that it's
not going to be the best in terms of how
to support their mental health right now
we know that a lot of the the
ways that they would normally draw
energy or get a mood boost are not
available to them so it's about thinking
as creatively as possible we try to
assess with people what the level of
relationship is with anybody they might
currently be socially distancing with
how they can make the most of those safe
in-person connections and then similarly
how they can connect with others to just
do daily activities kind of together the
sense of can you watch a tv show
together are there online games you can
connect with and play with other people
and i'll give one last quite creative
suggestion i've seen from some of the
teenagers i treat which is social
distancing walks in the sense that
they'll meet up across a block from each
other
never be on the same side of the street
but at least feel like they're walking
together and can look at each other you
know in person
that's fascinating because i think the
rational part of our brain says why does
it matter for watching that you know
that netflix show at the same time but
to your point there is something deep
inside of us that's saying oh other
people are experiencing at the same time
and that's the thing i'm deep into cheer
right now next up is tiger king but i
think for all of us
it's that you know if we don't have a
partner or another family member to
watch with it becomes a question of can
we watch with a friend or
uh you know do this over some sort of
online forum where somebody is on
facetime at the same time as uh we're
watching on television and we're
watching in real time together it at
least gives some sense of shared
experience particularly for extroverts
who really feed off that
yeah
that's cool cook the same food and then
share a meal that that's a that's a neat
idea
exactly and you get to compare you know
who did it best and you know kind of
tinker with each other's recipes there's
there's a lot that can happen with that
especially if your friend is a better
chef than you are
yeah
although you could pretend that your own
dish was the more delicious no one will
ever know
but but this is somewhat the lobby you
can always doing this
obviously we could do video versions of
this live stream uh and then it might
even you know we wouldn't have our
little technical glitches that sometimes
we have with our our
broadband
no no one should feel broadband guilt at
this point
but but this is the value that we're all
globally right now having this shared
experience and we're getting a ton of
more questions from facebook taylor
kobayan asks how do you cope with school
work load without getting distracted
personally as a high school student i'm
struggling with staying focused since i
have adhd advice
so my first job at the child mind
institute was running our clinical
center for kids with adhd and behavioral
issues so this is this is right in my
clinical wheelhouse so thank you for the
softball
i mean look with a lot of the the
patients that we're working with adhd
right now
um you know we know certain things we
know that if they get sleep focus can be
better if they take medicine it's
important to think about the timing and
when they're going to get the most
benefit from that and then beyond that
it's important to think about
organizational skills and the
structuring of the day so with a lot of
my patients right now will think about
especially with adolescents even though
they may be waking up slightly earlier
than they would say during the school
day we're structuring their work space
to make sure it's as free of
distractions as we can maybe putting any
distracting devices where friends might
be trying to contact us outside the door
elsewhere in the house we're trying to
get good work blocks in the day so
trying to make sure we've got at least
one work block before lunch and perhaps
starting with some of the more ambitious
tasks that we know will have less energy
to really tackle or focus to really
tackle later in the day structuring in
good meals and breaks and really trying
to not save a lot of the challenging
work more like the easy stuff you can
kind of knock off for the late night
time either when medicine or motivation
has really worn off and it's it's about
kind of you know managing yourself like
that and then if you can't talk back to
yourself to combat procrastination
effectively sometimes we've seen teens
and college students really try to get
accountability buddies who can kind of
keep them on task and say all right let
me meet with you for five minutes at the
beginning of the day what's your list
and then you know how can we make sure
we check in uh in a non-judgmental way
to keep you on track
that's super powerful a lot of what you
described once again the rational parts
of our brains like oh why should i have
to text message a friend when i've
checked something off of my off of my
to-do list or why should i have to eat a
you know watch a movie but there's
at the same time as someone else but
there's something very powerful about
having that uh that community
accountability to what you're doing and
we've talked about it at previous live
streams just just getting started having
those early wins but do some of the high
cognitive load things early with breaks
that's that's super good advice
and it's really also that friends can
help us be accountable in a more
non-judgmental way not to mention
friends are often the ones who are most
gentle with us in helping us to be
self-compassionate and also to realize
we deserve breaks even if we weren't as
efficient in a given day as we expected
we would be
you have better friends than i do mine
are quite
kidding me
carefully
yes you should see some of the text
accountability that i have with my
friends when we have one group where we
text each other whenever we uh eat
something we should not and
um they are not they are quite harsh we
are all harsh to each other
well
i've seen folks do things where their
friend will control a certain portion of
their money it'll be donated to a cause
they don't support if they you know
don't accomplish their goals but to a
cause they do support if it does you
know
you can set up lots of different you
know schemes for yourself with your
friends
that's powerful so so this next question
is from youtube and actually this is
something where we could probably both
take a stab at answering it youtube
ashutosh tewari says hi sal i want to
know how you people are coping with
covet 19. i want to know how
you all are keeping your offices running
and i'll take a stab at it and i'd love
to dave you know you're also in an
organization i'd love to think about how
you personally are coping in your
organization but uh ashitosh you know
khan academy it's this is a hard time
for everyone obviously
the some of the good things that khan
academy had going for it is we already
had about 35 of our workforce was what
we would say remote or distributed and
so
we had a lot of the infrastructure in
place where we could do meetings over
google hangouts or zoom
we would use
things like google docs to be able to
collaborate and so that that aspect of
it has been relatively okay for khan
academy although it's still been
difficult i think the part that's been
much harder is
now a lot of our team members are at
home
their children many of them have very
young children are at home and you can
imagine getting work done while you're
also doing child care especially if your
children are very young is very
difficult and i know many of the parents
and teachers out there listening are are
coping with the same thing you know i
consider myself very fortunate we have a
you know
i have three young children
my wife my mother-in-law lives with us
and that helps us kind of
be able to tag team a little bit and
especially since since the covid crisis
has been going on and khan academy's
load and in fact my workload has gotten
even higher than it typically would have
been even pre-crisis uh you know i
really have to thank my wife and my
mother-in-law for stepping up uh and
filling in the gap and my my wife is a
physician a rheumatologist so you can
imagine there's a lot of complexity in
her world as well so uh she's been kind
of the hero of the household lately but
it's it's tough on everyone and i think
we all just have to you know take one
step at a time and to quote frozen two
uh do the next right thing dave i'd love
to hear personally uh how are you coping
and your family and your work
i just thought my son's favorite
character is elsa so if i can mix
flexibility gratitude and frozen
references into my speech here uh you
know i think that that was pretty
perfect uh
no you know i think that at child mind
you know we have uh 300 employees across
a couple coasts and similar to you there
were aspects of our our work that were
as a non-profit that were already online
and uh you know fruitful for
collaboration even working at distance
i think others like clinical care
have both suffered and then also been
adapted in new and inventive ways to
serve our patients in the sense that
we all knew that the models of treatment
that we use for children adolescents and
families
are
are most tested in person but in in an
environment like this in many ways
we've seen organizations like ourselves
kind of
figure out how we can become borderless
in that we can serve with consultations
or or clinical care in really creative
ways using video camera coaching with
parents at home or all kinds of
different formats online
just to to get uh in touch with our
patients and to really make sure we can
provide support as best we can uh during
this time
like you uh i have a three-year-old and
a seven-month-old at home and the only
way that i've been able to function or
keep uh work up is because of my
wonderful wife and in-laws who also live
with us but even with that said my son
is used to a bounded lifestyle my son by
three-year-old
and where
daddy goes to work each day in an office
and he goes to his preschool
and the fact that i'm working upstairs
has been a real adjustment period for
him in the sense that he doesn't really
understand why he can't be involved in
everything and so i've tried to work out
a rhythm where i take a long lunch break
with him each day outside the yard
we you know have at least a meeting with
a team member of mine not a patient that
he joins each day and then i just try to
drop everything the second the work day
is over and spend a good bit of time
with him but i think everybody's trying
to find their balance that way you know
whenever i start to feel sorry for
ourselves uh because of my youngest is
five years old and he's a little bit
difficult sometimes i remind myself of
those of you who have a three-year-old
or seven months old
at home so
my sympathy
the funniest thing is that you know in
the midst of this i think my wife and i
had so many goals for you know where
we'd like him to be right now like you
know we've gotten through potty training
the last year like he's sleeping in his
own big kid bed and uh just the last few
nights i in the last week or so
he's found it unable to sleep through
the night without one of us in his bed
and we're just adapting to that like i
think in in the normal rhythm of life
we'd say to ourselves no we've got to
set some boundaries here but the reality
is our kids we're trying to stay healthy
we're trying to keep everybody safe and
their mood up so you know what's a
little bit of relaxing the boundaries
right now if it makes everybody feel
safe and loved
well that's actually a good segue to
this next question uh that i have here
uh and this is you know the screen time
question has always been a question but
obviously a lot of us are relying on
screen time uh both socially and
academically and work-wise so from
facebook samsing
sinet
or sine theta i thought it was a really
sine theta
trigonometric username i like that
sine sine theta is it good for kids to
go online for three hours in the morning
even with breaks some kids complain of
headaches and bleary eyes uh yeah i'd
love your you know there's the
pre-covered screen time debate and now
there's the
current coveted screen time debate
i i just did a webinar for parents on
this last week
where we talked about how pre-covid the
checklist was you know in terms of
stressing out over screen time balance
we asked parents let's check off a
number of developmental boxes and as
long as you've got those things you may
not have to worry about how much free
time your child is spending on screens
as long as you're kind of monitoring the
content and the interactions
we would check off you know are they
invested in school do they have
extracurricular activities do you have
some family time you know do they have
face-to-face contact with friends and
are they getting enough sleep those
would be some of the things on checklist
the way it's switched for covid is
around basic wellness practices and then
the fact that the balance has really
shifted in that we're asking parents
okay is everybody in the house eating do
you know where your food is coming from
let's check like kind of hierarchy of
needs type things you know do you feel
like everyone's getting enough sleep how
can we help with that are people getting
exercise in some form are you finding
ways to give yourself breaks above and
beyond school or work responsibilities
and you know it's it's this question of
once you've kind of checked off those
boxes of finding just ways to engage in
basic routines of wellness over the
course of the day we're trying to get
people to really think about relaxing
that you know if you want to focus on
say an hour or two a day to find screen
free activities destruction for kids
congratulate yourself and then you know
monitor the content and monitor what
they're watching of course but it's okay
to relax the boundaries during this time
and we'll snap them back over the summer
when everybody can be maybe outside and
hopefully when we're through this to
some degree
but yeah right it's an interesting
struggle because we're always you know
we always feel guilt to some i mean
there's good screen time and not so good
screen time or neutral screen time i
guess uh but obviously we're all leaning
on it more but it's your point all of
our own mental health we all need
actually might need some screen time to
connect with folks to learn but it also
if it can help offload a parent for even
half an hour an hour and give them a
break if their stress level goes down it
helps the student
and this goes back to the american
academy of pediatrics recommendations
related to screen time where you know
they're they're conservative but at the
same time they really focus on the idea
that mediated viewing with a child in
the sense that you watch something with
the kid and talk about it or educational
or high quality programming this is
going to sound like a plant but many of
my patients and families are watching
khan academy uh you know as as part of
this because you know in that sense
their parents have said look if my kids
are going to be on screens and that's
going to be how they're going to occupy
themselves through this crisis i may as
well make some good choices about what
i'm exposing them to and there will be
some time that i give them where they
choose it and then other times where i
say here's a forum that i know is all
high quality content choose from this
and occupy that self with something you
know like the boxer rebellion i saw
framed you know in your white or your
chalkboard behind you that's a great
thing
that has been my to-do for a while i
still have not made the boxer rebellion
uh i'm i'm well researched on it but i
haven't made it yet uh but in that case
we're previewing that it's coming
content that people can really get
it's been up there for a while i gotta
be careful when i write up there uh so
the next next question is maybe almost
almost the symmetric uh opposite of that
well maybe it's related from facebook
sarabi srivastava says how to manage a
teenager who's taking the quarantine
like fish to water need to break him
away from the screen with very limited
choices so this is a a parent who's
worried because it's maybe their child
really likes this
coveted world
is we're hearing that i'm sorry my my
reception is jumping again but we're
we're hearing that a lot from teenage
parents is that we get one of two
concerns in one two directions it's
either i'm worried about how my teenager
is gonna cope with the lack of you know
uh connection with friends how do i deal
with that and that kind of references
the answer i gave to an earlier question
and then there's the they're not coming
out of their room like you know do you
do you think they're depressed or could
it be that they're just you know not
liking time spent with their family or
they're liking this too much and all are
possible conclusions you know we've
helped many a parent to just kind of
think through the fact that your
teenager isn't is in their room may not
necessarily mean their mood is low or
they've experienced any disruption their
eating or sleeping patterns or you know
that they're feeling all hopeless
they may just be enjoying themselves
like a pig in mud um in that sense so
you know when when we see this kind of
thing with teenagers we've tried to talk
parents through
uh two kind of major strategies one is
just kind of trying to get to their
non-negotiables you know when do you
want your teenager out of their room
family meals at least an hour a day
maybe they've got to take a walk outside
because you've decreed they have to get
some exercise while practicing social
distancing um you know we get those
non-negotiables then the other thing
we've been coaching parents on is
strategies to keep the teenager out of
their room when they spontaneously
emerge so in that sense we try to coach
teenage parents or parents of teenagers
on uh you know trying not to pepper the
kiddo with questions the moment they
walk out use declarative statements
praise something you know they might
have done like it really seemed like you
were working on your english essay hard
earlier today or hey you know i'm making
spaghetti sauce you always know how to
make it just right you know it's that
you're you're trying to draw them out
with skills they have value to the
family you know and and conversation
rather than did you get your schoolwork
done today you know uh what else was on
your list which inevitably sends a
teenager back into their room so that's
that's kind of it
yeah i really like that last point you
know a lot of times i always say and
this isn't based in research but more
just gut senses you know teenagers
especially are proto-adults you know
biologically
nature would allow them to be even be
parents not recommending it by any
stretch of the imagination but that
implies that they are psychologically
and biologically capable of caring for
themselves and others but modern society
has kind of just kept them only worrying
about themselves and your last point
about helping with the pasta
it's really like hey let me i'm gonna
treat you like an adult or a proto-adult
a pre-adult i'm gonna give you some
responsibility for the household as well
well i think what you're highlighting is
the uh intersection of resources uh
social economic status uh cultural
background and maturity in the sense
that you know
in within kind of american culture we
have sort of a period of extended
adolescence in which we really very
gradually ask teenagers who are seeking
novelty or seeking new experiences uh to
take on responsibilities uh now that is
very much converging with the fact that
if parents are experiencing job
insecurity during this time or they're
overwhelmed for child care we're often
asking teenagers to take on a larger
share of responsibility in a crisis like
this one or when someone is is
confronting that kind of uh you know uh
situation just in general so it really
you know the question of teenager takes
to covet a little bit too much
usually entails the fact that that
teenager's main responsibility prior to
this was perhaps school and
you know that in some sense it's okay if
we're a little bit stricter about the
idea that we need some help during this
time and and it may be it may behoove
them to kind of serve the family a
little bit better than
they might have otherwise since their
day job school has sort of uh shifted a
bit
yeah and i think we have time for maybe
one more question there's a couple of
questions that are in this category uh
this is this is uh from several folks
who are talking about feeling stressed
either when they're trying to learn a
specific thing like math or their pr or
reading or feeling stressed because they
actually have a fairly large to-do list
from school and they're feeling like
they're not able to do it what tips you
have to those students who are feeling
stressed
yeah i mean part of it is that i think
everybody's managing this crisis
together so more so than ever it both
feels alone but you're not alone so you
know the the reality is we're hearing
from so many students who will tell us i
can't manage the workload or i i feel so
ashamed because the the other students
seem to be taking this online learning
like a fish out of water but not me and
i don't we don't really meet people who
are finding it easy during this time so
i think it's more that we want to
encourage people to reach out to their
fellow students for how they're coping
with this and to reach out to their
teachers because we're all i think
you know functioning on more limited
time and kind of headspace than we
normally have but at the same time we
want to help like we know that uh switch
from in-person to online schooling will
not come without bumps and so for that
reason we've seen teachers more so than
ever you know interested in connecting
really quick individually to try to help
a student through something or figure
out how they can get support and i think
that a lot of teenagers we see in
college students are really surprised by
that
yeah and i'll just add to that because
we've been seeing that type of stress
not just amongst students using khan
academy but we've been seeing it even in
our own employee base where you know
folks have you know their head space is
shrunk there's a baseline of anxiety or
dread going on and then they're taking
care of kids they have might have a
family member who's having financial
difficulty because they lost i mean
there's just all sorts of stresses that
are going on and then they're also
trying to do their work and they're
feeling almost guilt or stress they're
like oh my god the goals that i thought
i was going to be able to do are not
realistic anymore and what we're telling
our team members and what we tell
everyone is no one is judging anyone
right now anyone i only judge the people
who are judging others
we keep telling folks you take
bite-sized chunks and then you do it in
this as high quality as you can but
don't think about quantity or the same
productivity right now no one's capable
of it
right and no one is judging it and and
you just have to release yourself i
think for example a lot of schools even
my own children's schools they've given
a very robust list of things for the
students to do but i i i think i can
speak on their behalf they completely
get that if uh kids or their parents are
not in a position to keep the kids to do
everything on that checklist it's
completely okay we're all trying to cope
with this situation in whatever way we
can
so uh dave thanks so much for joining
we're at time every day this you know
this half an hour goes by fast and today
was even faster than normal a sign of
how much fun we're having uh i think
you're gonna be able to join us uh
hopefully in
future live streams and i just want to
tell everyone as what dave and i just
said uh you know you you might feel
physically separated from others and
dave gave some good ideas for how you
might become feel a little bit mentally
closer uh or emotionally closer to
others in this type of crisis and the
whole point of this live stream is for
all of us to realize that we're in this
together the whole world is going
through this
so as best as you can uh you know keep
safe and stay healthy and don't beat up
yourself too much and and take some time
to breathe relax meditate whatever it
takes to kind of give yourself that that
mental reset
we'll see you tomorrow
any brilliant advice
you